[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
hello everybody and welcome to the
Friday stream with me John Luke and Joey
how's it going
the J&J stream as are we gonna call it
the Taser and calling it get Jake in
here to be the JJ and Jesu I like that
I'm just gonna yeah scrunch up yeah
cheering here we are playing Flint took
which is a indie game that came out
about a month ago
yeah it's about almost exactly a month
ago yeah April 18th but we haven't had a
chance to check it out here so we were
gonna check it out that's kind of what
we're thinking the premise of this our
Friday stream will be so far is that we
kind of want to cover smaller games that
haven't had a chance to get much like
coverage yeah not a lot of attention but
there are a lot of like quality games
out there that exactly I know a lot of
people might not just they just might
not know about so you can watch the
intro for this one this is actually like
this yeah
[Music]
it's a good intro I like the look at
this game I like his like bag on his
head it goes bad yeah he's a pirate
space pirate right reminds me of a
candle Jack his head they're familiar
with candle jack Buju no he's from
freakazoid
oh you know I never watched that I
always always saw the commercials before
but never actually got around to it
freakazoid man I love that era of WB
cartoons I think I mostly just watched
anime neon yeah maniacs
and Max is really really good they have
that all in Netflix or at least they did
at one point so he's like a pirate right
yeah this guy fired like I stole his
bottle of something go son
that's his son
I don't know I've been baking of things
I don't have a lot of those games
cool all right let's just jump right
into this okay
[Music]
I am going to be reading the comments so
if you have any questions about the game
or us or whatever it's Friday
casual Friday just you know talk with us
so we're here for the grappling so the
movement
man you're just zipping yeah yeah you
played a little bit I just kind of get
used to the controls yeah they're very
very tight yeah
like literally I like the speed of
everything so you got your basic jump
you got your gun here and then you got
the grappling hook now when you hit with
the grappling hook you don't stay on the
object like you can't like hold in like
uh you might be able to from what I
played it seemed like you kind of
thought keep it moving yeah I think that
you might find like some ability later
on that allow you to hold on to it but
thanks for now like the idea is that you
see this little little knob or little
circles there you you can just grapple
onto that and you can fly which are
going to make our video box bigger Tay
was saying how he should have been small
like that's uh that's on you Tay like
trying
I could try maybe just that I will admit
my knowledge of Kay's like showed me
multiple times how to do this and I'm
like not don't mess anything up yeah I
don't want to like screw it out there
editor
I'll try and figure that out you keep
playing the game oh my god I'm moving a
thing oh it's all it's all bad
doing the stream am i messing this whole
thing out there
the bomb
so quick rundown my abilities I can slow
down time man okay
what what's going on here alright Gupta
stay so we got we got dissenting
opinions here oh boy I don't know how to
do it now I mess up the the pip pickle
it's fine
hashtag like oh yeah you can for you to
blame me for this but hey hey he's
coming in to save me
so the bad guy yeah I think so well he's
got a spaceship well it will be tired
yeah the entire game takes place in
space
oh it's actually lovely place yeah for
some reason I was thinking this was one
of those Metroidvania tech games that
Indies really like making yeah but you
know it's good to have something like
this like once in a while yeah a little
more straightforward
[Music]
a little bit bigger now that's too big
oh I don't know
sure
hmm multiple ways and we go with that
one why not
[Music]
is there some good music here we go
ooh much better thanks day
I know how to operate a TriCaster but I
don't know when it comes to exploit eggs
well what do we do it get that where
it's like you know how to operate like
the really like advanced like
professional equipment but then it comes
to like a really basic like easy to use
commercial thing you're like I don't
understand this
yeah this is this is too simplistic
audience
at this menu they're fine
all right we're good
I think we're good back to the game so
as most of the game you're in this
pirate base I think most of it is yeah
just like some levels will but I think
right now we're on a ship of some sort
hmm
oh so there's a map on yeah yeah okay so
I like a Metroidvania but you know still
a level base that's interesting what
could we get me are that killed you
tough experience I can't afford it ooh
harkaman generous yeah make me waste all
my money guys respond or did you just
not count it I okay come on mother
I guess if they respawn you can probably
find them yeah smack of life we get
adjust the camera while you were down
which Holmes is always look towards the
horizon
hit the [ __ ] coxswain Busey [ __ ]
coxswain fourth writes a critical name
as good names a good pirate name
we got the map sweet
I can't see a bigger box and read
comments ah dude okay [ __ ] definitely
not happen to reading the comments
though if you guys have any questions
please uh let us know oh oh dude you're
gonna die
what lady you got a 500 that was okay oh
no I'm having a little bit hard hard
time seeing the looks of the but there's
the number right yeah but it's like the
whole diamond around it around the
health bar right just likes a little
weird I see what we got our hard packs
um got a free hook here
this game is microtransaction like no
that's an indie game like this ever
dared to put in my friends I don't think
so feel like I mean technically you
could still be an indie game and half of
that but I feel like you get your cred
your indie cred hooked right
man's music oh this is a boss now I
think it's just a little wave let's see
if I cannot take heat damage here it's
tough because your aim is on their mind
movement yeah that's the thing is like
you move toward them and your shoot
lettuce a little a little tricky
[Music]
that's good hey how you doing that um
slow motion just a left trigger okay
a bubble around them
Liz James says joy needs to be in waffle
man mode I don't know that has been it
sounds delicious
oh she's referring to always with the
the mystery men the references here oh
okay I went to that one went over my
head
not not familiar
we've chosen snapping to hopes feel so
good yeah it really does
I can mow mentum that you get from that
it's like pretty cents game is a
satisfying a hook you could say yes
reluctantly I will say that
I thought you were gonna make me save
them but ah kill everything
[Music]
way up nice yeah feels really good to
stuff oh no I'm okay
all right I can see this gaming it real
hard with that no it's part of you know
kind of thing I'm almost gonna figure
out where you want to go
what if you go to the right and then
give it I can't get past those a boxes
there oh really
please right now right now Oh Oh No
if you look at the map there's nowhere
to go I think it was there just for the
treasure yeah good one so are we free to
play as much as you want or we need to
stop somewhere well I mean at some point
we have to do other things and there is
going to be another stream at - Jake and
I believe Rob are going to be playing a
ex machina next schmuck next Mach enough
inside so yeah but uh we'll probably go
for at least an hour
explore a little bit more around here
whoa that's what that's one of those
things okay
okay I'm on 30 health here yeah the
hooks that feels good the shooting seems
a little loose in terms of like not
trying to take damage yeah
Oh goose is I mean if you like can't go
pass elects or whatnot no we in the
games now we don't have any like in
Scripture restrictions oh yeah
the full game it has been released you
can buy it yourself I've got Ryan
Schubert up in the YouTube chat
moderating be nice to him
you know him be nice to everyone this
lovely lovely Friday okay we've got a
met coins all right so it looks like
there's a boss to the left of us here I
guess I can take them all with 40 health
yeah sure give you a challenge
Oh started off great
[Music]
look
[Music]
Oh Joey Joey yeah I was good little mini
balls go back get back
No Oh would you die from that
heartbreaking chest over here says I'm
definitely picking this one up for long
plane flights yeah with my own PC and
this would be great on the switch I know
I just I didn't sing that about
everything yeah by mean I think I
mentioned this to you like right before
we started streaming is there is like
another like a like position five former
indie game right Celeste that's coming
out sometime this year it'd probably
come out in the summer um well yeah
that's on the switch in that that one's
really fun that's played a little bit of
it couple months ago
jacoub Johnny says but this being a
roguelike do you feel like you're
actually progressing or nah I mean we
haven't really died much no I mean it
I wouldn't say it's like it's what were
they call those those rogue lights where
if you die the yeah keep all your stuff
still looks I think it just went back to
though Chernobyl oh you look so sad
that's because I just quit the quit the
level
yeah he's saying that some roguelikes
feel like you're never progressing like
enter the gungeon yeah enter the gungeon
was a weird one where it's a good game
but I feel like at a certain you reached
a certain point in that game where it
felt like it was too like grindy to
progress and too difficult for me can
you stream PC games to switch now I
can't do anything like that
doesn't really have any other sort of
like all mine like came to like browse
on the switch no brows are younger
gooses jails been drinking that switch
kool-aid heck dad it tastes so slim what
were we on I'm trying to figure out
stack this one hmm
all right just pick one do did you see
the splatoon switch controllers no oh
you mean the the joy comes right at the
joy counts the colors the joy count
calories yes I saw and very sad that I
don't know if it will come come to
America propose it is it only I thought
I read it was Jeff Japan Olli and I was
like oh dude I want that what my sorrows
like ah like I let out a Yelp in in the
office but oh it's only even have it for
the pro controller and I was already
happy so controller do you mean they
have for the broker there's a pro
controller that also of the grits have a
degree in are you serious oh my god and
I didn't play Mario Kart with my
girlfriend and she's like man I really
like to play on the pro controller I was
like maybe I'll get you a pro controller
so maybe I should get that thing but I
also want those it's like totally like
excess like I shouldn't bother buying
yeah I really want the that pink and
green
Cosmo Wanda joy Kahn's speakers Cosmo
and Wanda
fun fact in injustice to which like
everyone in the office has been playing
a whole bunch of Harley Quinn who the
voice of hers
Tara's strong yeah who a lot of people
might none or might know that she plays
the voice of Timmy Turner in yeah we all
care yeah and her hyenas as the pets in
injustice car engine green pink it down
green hair is that from look cuz I think
she has quite Highness in the comics
part is that a reference to and oh I
want to believe that it yeah I do too oh
can we got us on him don't think so look
at that dude he's just just giving up on
life resigned to his fate
[Music]
that has been revealed all right summer
war this time
go down really
that seems now oh right over there okay
that's good maybe that's get rid of it
oh I was clever on their end he knew you
could stand there Oh see it my then so
walk across but out I'm okay I got 90
health let's make our way back up
[Music]
you
[Music]
uh yes so far I mean these are all
randomly generated but they connect
pretty well yeah I think that's a real
key aspect to a roguelike ISM having the
random elements all connect well and
they don't fight they feel intentional I
don't want the enemies inside these guys
they're like they're like what big
puffer fish yeah big eyes are like
squishing explode into spikes you're
adorable
they remind me of those nasty-looking
the clam things in from Donkey Kong
Country 3
I don't you ever seen so now it really
really grows something down here see
[Music]
like I even do anything
oh just standing there you use kill them
once yeah more speed
it's me and I go to speak
like we're going all the way back up
[Music]
this okay
oh I'll take it you're good
wait something about oh damn it never
progeny son says I hope Microsoft and
Sonny make controls with Rumble soon uh
I mean the rumbles cool when it but also
like I mean so far like not long games
head Oh haven't really taken advantage
of and not a whole lot like they have
what I think if once you switch is
probably the most egotistical yeah I'm
waiting for like a needed a a WarioWare
game they haven't made one in a while
and I adore they made one for for the
Wii U right I was like gaming Wario it
was like oh that's I it was only a
download yeah wasn't downloadable and it
wasn't like a true warrior where game um
they haven't made up though I think the
last proper warrior where game was the
we won it was a smooth move smooth moves
which I like that one actually quite a
bit I like the multiplayer was really
really fun cuz you'd have to like keep
passing off the controller yeah
fantastic
I think one I think my favorite worry
worked with stood the Game Boy Advance
that one's really good yeah and that had
the motion sensor in that yes yeah like
they they always know what it like take
advantage of like Nintendo's bizarre
gimmick so a thing like you know HD
Rumble is something that they could
totally do the banjo apparently goob
there's no Vita version of this game so
not able to take it on a plane
whoo well maybe they'll maybe the switch
that the switch is the new Vita in that
sense I don't know if you want to say
that well as in as far as like
portability all right quality
affordability and quality of games and
murder ground which is very cool indeed
it's like that but the switch is gonna
be the place where you're going to see
all the portal Indies now which really
just means the Vita is that much more of
a dead system unfortunately like I was
thinking about that like I have a I'm
Bonnie Isaac on here on my switch I got
a shovel knight and I was like all right
well like you put spelunky on it and I
never need to turn on mine again and
then uh was a star to valleys coming to
its yeah oh man dude that is gonna be
the best to connect hub oh you just give
us as I just jinx the switch what's the
black market oh no that's the packets
right yeah
so family I was at this one it's got
it's a little hard to tell since I'm not
sure which direction it's actually
pushing me if I'm pulling it or pushing
it eternal nightmare says yo what's good
e your Twitter is my main source of
gaming news
that's rad yeah we post all sorts of
stuff Shiva is a church of a social on
Twitter and she does a fantastic job
yeah many a times if I've like put up a
video at like on Sunday and I was like
hey hey Shiva no can see this but uh
supposed to get some social on it and
she's like no problem and I'm like oh
it's really nice oh we got some bleed so
it's okay
a new area here whoa oh uh yeah well I
think on our news site like right now
the big thing is a destiny which I got
to go see yesterday yeah la what a
pretty good right yeah I enjoyed it
quite a bit especially I got to check
out the PC version mouse the keyboard
which is like really really cool I like
that game are like 60 frames a second
you know strike me as someone he's
played much much is destiny no not a lot
doesn't see you guys playing or hear you
about you guys playing all the time so
go ships comforters this guy's a damn
map for it no that's a sleeping bag for
a head coop says you don't have any
abilities I have the hook I got the hook
we got the time thing done I have bombs
which I don't really have any of right
now I say oh there's a shield I can't
afford it
yeah I need a seven more I'll come back
for you yeah yeah go up that uh we good
no people and asked me about destiny
yeah I guess I hate the hijack with
dream but I yeah if you want to ask me
some destiny questions I can certainly
answer them
how does Sentinel arc start not count as
a class they are subclasses the same way
in destiny 1 they were like multiple
subclasses those who are the new
subclasses for the Titan and hunter
respectively
Charl dimer Monson it was the console
locked at 30 frames per second for
destiny - from what we played yeah we're
playing them on pros at 1080p locked at
30 which is really which is a bit weird
right you think if it's running on a pro
that doesn't have four cases it does
anything so I think it does have four
case support I think they just had it at
1080 because we were all capturing it
yeah you can't really capture
well you can't capture 4k but that have
been such a hassle so I think that's why
but I would have imagined like oh if you
have a 1080p it would be over 160 right
on the pro yeah it's also possible that
they don't have that stuff where you get
like those settings well I don't know
like for now it was at 30 but maybe
later doing with CF 4k will see this
window at 4k oops is waiting for that
new class skill breakdown right here in
GameSpot actually I mean today we're
talking about this morning about stuff
we might do it so we might actually have
something up like that we do have a
impressions that me and Tay shot there
that I'm going to edit
and uh get out this weekend for you guys
okay I need to go back to that guy get
some meat in the shields
yeah I judge you went ahead you could
check out that other room on the till
though he's have to call it way back uh
no I'm gonna head that way anyway unless
it was is there another room whatever we
can go down for that far
look at that dude look at his face oh I
love the enemy design all right here we
go
get some space meat I'm a shield what is
this one two o'clock okay before that oh
it's probably all that road probably
extra slow down yeah long longer slow
down sit back up might have to make a
Titan named goob did you mean what you
mean goo in a destiny one meet more meat
a meat shop
god no my shield I guess it's only good
for one hit warlock main not bad not bad
I I dig I did get to try give the dawn
blade which is the new subclass for the
warlock where you're flying in the air
with like solar angel wings and you're
throwing solar blades at people it was
pretty cool
dizzy death wants to know can we break
the pops and barrels to get extra
coinage to something oh yes we can
oh you can yeah it's weird because
sometimes like sometimes you're in the
background I'm Brown well yeah like that
okay so yeah alright totally again
she'll turn light mirror wants no we're
gaining spots located relocating good
old San Francisco yep um probably
Christian which my Rebecca says how is
everyone
I'm I'm very good thank you pretty good
I had slight headache in the this
morning now I am feeling better
alright it's been a pretty it's pretty
busy we happy where the guy was all with
destiny
all that dropping yeah it sounds like it
was pretty crazy just you guys don't
bones yeah it was a good uh dump of
information III Pratt but like a meanie
III day for us in that sense
can you read ships no scratch it gets
some no-man's land
really it's like I guess I put a
challenge thing maybe like a reward do
it Joey I don't think I could I think
that answers our question everyone
donal it looks good but warlock cuz I'm
as weak as a PvP so I don't know no I've
never been much the PvP guy sometimes
like the PvP meta commentary in the PvP
so the other thing looks pretty cool
seem pretty cool to me
actually I've ever I should like put
that up on a whatever some is the the
whole gameplay breakouts not good enough
to put up but set one like you could do
that thirty second thing I'll be good
dude I had I don't know if you ever had
this at an event but I get in and
playing the multiplayer like alright
let's do this and it's I gotta get in
the match someone's inverted the
controls Hey look at nothing wrong with
in oh right oh right I forgot yeah yeah
alright
yeah but they also set the sensitivity
to ten - like the max so it was just
awful and I'm like sitting here like all
right let's try get a good clean
recording you know forever site and it's
instantly I'm like I have to go to the
settings and change all that get that
buffer
oops relation Oh No
yeah the spider ideals are far away oh
how there's a combo meter over on the
bottom the bottom right just probably
just like I wonder if wonder that does
anything probably get more more money
from that
oh maybe let's go down bombs healing
rocks GT says OMG got a pro Genji it
says OMG is that a pro Genji who me I
don't know I'm not sure he's referring
to going like this zipping around
zipping around tonic 640 gold just
squeeze me
so I can only hold one bomb at a time so
in that little diamond in the corner we
only have one one special ability for a
lower location for collection wonder
what the reasoning is that some
roguelikes don't worry like like funny
guys it goes is where you will like get
an item and it's like Oh
data you've collected this item it'll
mount show up more often oh that's
pretty cool um so I'm wondering if
that's what that means
cuz I'm not sure you're like I'm not
necessary interested in reading like the
more exactly
so today suggested platformer games like
this for ps2 and Android ooh yes - yes -
yes - Mary didn't really have any of
these kinds of games is he looking for
like recommendations for his use - that
sounds like a sore Android for the phone
um making a phone I just got a telephone
Oh add that to the red light - the relic
I guess like all the old treasures that
have been lost at this point in time
money for ER oh I don't think so I'll
actually maybe I have 500 now which
might be a little bit more but I don't
really know any Android uh
platformers apart from like that Mario
Mario Clan Martin run sumaya run okay
that's like a Metroid whoa type of
offering tale yeah nice nice you shoot
those bombs before they blow up I don't
think so they dig detonate really
quickly yeah oh no getting faster faster
like I think one of the things that
really contributes to the game feeling
like satisfying to move is that every
time you use the hook like you stole you
have that momentum it's not just like a
dedicated jump art that's the same every
time like depending on where where you
hook on to it like this old little
thrust me a little bit more in that
direction really like Gwen Don yes this
is currently available the games
actually been out for like a month now
it is we're playing it on Steam but I
believe you can get it on yes it's
available on PC I believe it's also
available on ps4
I'll check I got one more go stream to
go I thought that's his compass I think
thanks for thanks for joining us eternal
rain blog appreciate having you on yes
the game is available on ps4 and also
Xbox one is it according to that little
window on the side check as well make
sure yep seems like it yeah
so yes available on all major current
platforms except for the switch I would
not be surprised if this end of them on
the switch at some point though
yep goog cut up on the twitch at 15
bucks freeze up miscreants frost globes
sub-weapon yeah I don't play that many
or I haven't played that many roguelikes
I think one of my favorite though is a
crypt of the necrodancer oh that one's
good
that was like one way everyone ever
played that with a dance I've always
wanted to meet my friends we used to do
a public access show ever we played
games and I bought a dance pad like
anyone I see that pretty cheap one yeah
that was good man the hook way up into
it oh it's oh damn that's tricky oh yeah
yeah I like a cheap like PC mouse pad or
dance pad for like 30 40 bucks I'm like
yeah um and then I don't know my friend
was like oh I have a friend who like
bought like a really like like crypt of
the necrodancer specific like $200 one
it was like I also where did your friend
like was that they probably had that as
like via if it did have a Kickstarter
for that very maybe or something anyway
I can see that being like Kickstarter
really nice it was like did you get this
but we played two-player co-op where we
both had goals you have and it is so fun
but it's also just tiring it's really
tiring but it's completely possible to
play that game that way and it's it's
amazing OOP several new people in the
chat hello everybody hello friends
we're talking about playing crypt of the
necrodancer on a dance pad that'd be a
fun thing to do in the office we should
do that oh my corns good yeah well I
don't I don't think that games relevant
right now watch yeah I don't care I
actually just recently got the
the vinyl for the for that game
soundtrack for decretal of the music in
that game I now have two vinyls video
game vinyls and and no vinyl player yet
so I need to I need to buy a player go
go on it I have an extra one
you do yeah Oh tonic what does this do
maybe you go on to buy that off of you
know I just spent 700 gold on it
whatever I think I just healed myself
full okay well alright
nothing ends then just joining him the
in the YouTube chat another moderator be
nice yeah nice to everyone who's
spinning blades see which way should we
go
how do you go oh oh okay oh hi guys you
could just wall jump your meatboy skills
going you're playing me play yeah I I
never be the fool I am
I've never okay I've never won a hundred
percent doing it but I have gotten
pretty far I've gotten me main ending
several times and I did do the alternate
ending once that is a game that I go
back and I'll play one for you I mean
like so many games so many indie games
like platformers say like they owe their
existence to like Super Meat Boy like
mechanics so that one just feels like so
good like it's like my when you hear
people talking about how like oh I'll go
back and I'll play like Mario yeah
original Mario or I'll play Mario for
real every year like me boys my Mario at
all see that way and it's like it's so
funny like back when I first got it took
me like I don't like a week or two and
you like slowly grinding it now I know I
can do that first level I threw in like
you know I could do the first whole
world but no deaths you know why they
still have like a really fun time
fwr wants to know what's roguelike about
this game so it is randomly generated
areas and also randomly generated
abilities that you can find like yep
now smile on them does money come over
yeah yeah money does the money carries
over
I don't you die though if they don't
worry if you're dying
go get me start everything when you died
uh barely some level I'm not sure if you
get to keep the thing is you only get in
one one ability ahead of time so it's
not like you have like a whole set that
you hold on to like right here I just
picked up a bomb yes it seems like yeah
we were convention to early that it
seems a little more rogen lights yeah
then maybe roguelike MLG Super Meat Boy
player John later yeah
I've ever do eSports for how would you
be born sports for that now I mean you
do a speedrun
oh I would love to watch it does he do
that in like awesome games done quick oh
yeah that's my point
I mean like I feel like Super Meat Boy
is a little uh like they've done so many
times I probably weighed out yeah I mean
like that the very least we'll probably
find like different ways to do it like a
race or blindfold the right thing yeah
good point I probably look up some good
speedruns up
or like maybe like speed run with a
particular character yeah you've ever
done it with the bolsa wolves one
character that you can do it as like an
axe or like a hammer my jumping game I
don't know oh my god there's they have
it they've added like different versions
have some characters remember the
remember when Tito made like a flash
game called like super tofu boy or
something a Tuesday yeah they basically
made a game that was like lamb fasting
like meat boy and the falling like
murder or whatever even though like they
were like nah man like he's not he's not
me he's a boy without skin like that's
the premise major they just see meat and
they're like ah but uh they added in
they patch into the steam version super
tofu boy very cool but his uh his jump
is too short and you can't beat the
first level I think I think someone was
able to beat the first level with him
and then get to the second but they
couldn't do that funny that's pretty
good good little jab when we got all the
ghost rims I found out about how to you
so we have to go to that yeah
boom bad Billy bullseye one mean
scallywags schemes very wholesome no I
gotta love it like the music is reminded
me of a I guess an OPS music but just
like the pirate aesthetic yeah do you
murder the old goof troop game for the
Super Bowl yeah we're like the entire
game is like like all the enemies are
pirates and yeah they're like really
goofy and silly like this seemed like a
great game for kids what was that about
whoa got a tail okay all but bubble that
means something I need to destroy at
some point
hmm
what if you hit the guy on the top oh oh
I pull it off oh you're asking for it
good wants to know do you remember what
levels beep later we just I think we're
just kind of pushing through it
okay we're call specifics I'll let you
focus okay he's got the fish dudes yeah
yeah no no that's not good I was gonna
say what's that egg thing
[Music]
dark blazing says if I read this message
it means you think we should put in more
memes up movie means more means we got
bunny that over on our Facebook so want
that a hot meme content it over to uh
GameSpot's Facebook account cut your
mean coverage or Gary here Joe is just
trying to stay alive yeah
can't can't focus I have 1000 dude
what's that what's that thing you want
to bomb alright first death or maybe
second let's see what happens
game over walk a couple things
solid effort okay so that rooted is back
then let's look at this other stuff
we've all gotta check I'm kind of
curious it's under lore we got just
basically all the uh-oh
you know if I use an actual or okay
we have a telephone in here when I pick
the course out of the relic yeah so I
got a telephone in pod musical
instruments since the only person
holding the handset can hear the music
it makes whether we do is achievements
Bravo
it only helps Helen right now and black
market this is where you can buy your
abilities right extra things see I have
five five of that currency let's see
reward with gold for in Indian bells
swiftly so these are permanent upgrades
I think so yeah free unlock free name
long okay
so yeah if you want yeah like you were
saying about how the the direction is
also your movement so now you can lock
it ah yes that's expressed more stamina
publicly and get probably one of these
yeah or actually that's a twofer yeah
maybe it's maybe teaching us more perks
expands over first you can whip I think
I'll probably go with stamina using your
opponent's let's go from I looks camera
first
back in
we got some weaponeer increases your
chances of finding supplements and
tracks faraway gold and jewels that's
pretty useful so I'm supposed to point
in this game well very it's a roguelike
so you kind of go through see how far
you can get unlock a bunch of new
abilities keep going okay so the perks
is are the things you can quit before
each round ah for each level you can
actually put a decent number of perks on
yeah so I only have three slots right
now I think oh I'll go with the extra
help Oh dizzy Jess says the speed boosts
upgrade gives me a nice Alucard tracer
effect why right now okay I'll get it
next time yeah I want to see that
[Music]
right free-spinning skulls sub-weapon
[Music]
this is not the boss I think it starts
you over oh it does it I think so okay
then
ready
where that road like stuff comes in and
that's cool
[Music]
look at the points oh no it's a damage
oh oh man over Oh night that's a rough
room
oh no that oh I only need to destroy
that thing in order hook okay fine
okay oh nice got a little walk
oh that you dark blue skin yeah we
always like reading the chat interacting
with our viewers
[Music]
oh I can pull off their other bubbles
[Music]
get that map
3/4 it yeah
is there a mana cost for using the time
slowed down
sumaya right no but you can only do it
for like oh yeah you got that time that
little meter there le set is that's
pretty for it seems kind of crucial back
to you yeah look at a mana meter though
D cool maybe a bit rough
yes it's just gonna do nothing yeah
what's up with them I sort of feel bad
that you're just like filler
oh of course it puts a bear
Anton yes we are playing this on the PC
although this game is out on the ps4 and
Xbox one for 15 bucks
[Music]
anything tell me so
skinbag of us problems pirates better 5
extra HP argh
no no oh of course
oh it's so mean
you know that I'm fine second so how do
we unlock the boss last time I think it
was through the the ghost gems you have
to find a certain yeah
[Music]
oh he was and get hook and Joey hook
like your life depends on it
it does
[Music]
all right space shell goes Jim let me
find another two more
[Music]
so is there always one in every area
yeah okay and that's a people level yeah
yeah goes Tim so basically it's like do
three levels by the box and hopefully
you don't die and then hopefully don't
and then I guess the idea would be like
the other roguelike thing is sort of
hoping that you get like some good gear
and don't have like your your health is
fine by the time you get to the ball
yeah have all those perks online just
look looking and swinging cubing the
chat with a good good puns
good is a arguable I love it
he's got me hooked
trying to concentrate here Oh a dude or
flies whatever those things are
this all this money man I know I want to
get that purse where it's just like I
just I just already absorbs everything
oh it does
fools bleed help okay it's trying to be
a little more careful that's my elbows
ten Oh
[Music]
let there be a store somewhere oh my god
oh dude you're not gonna make it oh oh
no Cooper says he'd even realize he made
the pun sure sure sure yeah I only
believe that there's a black market was
the one that was accustomed to write
extra to extra perks okay I'm gonna get
there
I can't won't try that speed thing guy
was mentioning so there's also
challenges to me look at those yet
challenges I don't think so no guys our
daily challenge jaylene weekly
challenges oh I guess is like getting
this level yeah spelunky and gameplay
finalizing have that where it's a
specific configuration that you then go
through and you try and see how much you
get through that world also have extra
HP you know try something different
hello Justin thanks for joining us
quick hook is free from puns are like
the minds of comedy
maybe sure that means the missiles can
imposes I'll take that seems cool that's
infeasible
so uh number next it with the skull on
the ships when you're going through the
ships show it might be the difficulty
yeah there's like a one two and three
okay GUP just hates mines combine them
or puns I wasn't sure we're doing this
prefered well he hates puns he says
minds are like pun or puns are like
mines apparently he just hates puns and
mine alright I've never actually seen a
mime in person actually I saw one oh
where was I it was I was in the city
somewhere and he was just like to sit
standing around his phone just gonna be
like a French thing right I think so
yeah I was I went to Paris once I didn't
see any moms there I don't think they
just walk around I think maybe 82 that's
where I went someone
if people play like the we'll play like
the violin in my massive string
instruments in the subway tunnels of
Paris but no mines no mimes that'd be
great those two were just next to each
other though a giant cello and then a
mime I'm liking this pinball thing yeah
that's me cuz even if you hit like next
to them and sometimes ricocheting
[Music]
mine's just walk around like people on
the street when some people do goo
that's like I think that's the only mom
ever seen in the wild wild lot because
everything I've seen about mines are
just on TV and yeah you know this movie
called uh shakes the clown no Bobcat
Goldthwait No
so the idea is like you know clowning is
in that world a profession okay and like
they're they're having regard there I
mean it kind of is I mean like specific
like very various like taking pretty
seriously okay like they have their own
like clubs and yeah like a clown's
specific bar that they always attend and
it's just they just wear alter my louder
aircraft yeah like all the time that's
just who they are apparently and in the
movie they they have like this huge
rivalry with my mind and like they hate
mimes but I think it's really good
because uh Robin Williams actually plays
he has a cameo as I just one of the lead
mines you like to see she's the main
character like out of out of mine
he was like come to traitor of sorts
he betrays the clown for the mimes
[Music]
[Music]
also enjoying the the gold magnet thing
I don't do that close to a tame yeah
that's nice
what oh no you know I kill him I guess
he's like a ghost cheese this is just
good yes it's a storeroom get out of
there
nice we get we get some apples all right
[Music]
[Music]
just now filling up a bad joke oh no
what have we started you can see like
the I guess the difficulty corresponds
to with the size of the ship as well oh
yeah so maybe like the small ones are a
little bit quicker quicker to finish
maybe maybe I would like to see it take
another stab at the boss yeah I think by
then I'll have a lot more a lot more
gear interesting do you see that that
tooltip was it you could get a perk that
allows your hook to still move in normal
speed when you move in slo-mo oh yeah
actually I do that I have that oh you do
at least I think I do
it seems pretty quick could be wrong
though
so it was called like the free hook yeah
first I had that illness I think like
they mean as far as aiming it possibly
like that oh I know they're very not
actual like speed if the hook maybe not
that no no Spidey's once I don't fully
get how these work so they'll they're
timed along with the platform's I rotate
to the side
odd I can't book it lets go feel fair
it's Gardens the galaxy to worth
watching
I don't know I haven't seen it soon
what's this one or cerasale should see
it oh that's a price tag so yes you're
gonna get get specials in every oh man
so everything everything is cheaper
whatever third five to my HP and Sam
potion just in case opposed should be
good for a boss though yeah well I think
it heals you right away
Oh
[Music]
let's begin a healing don't know why I'm
having some trouble here just like in
your attempt to avoid the one bullet and
not take damage yeah I just like taking
damage from yeah like the wall I'll do
that all the time in games ii am i doing
go end on thank you for joining us for
the screen we really appreciate it yeah
the game i this game is really cool i
definitely wanna play more Joe you're
actually playing on my account so you're
getting oh oh cool yeah you're getting
me all the sweet stuff I'll probably
start over just like it on my own my own
experience
these guys are just like hey hey
roadblocks but yeah sup oh oh oh get
some elf Joey some apples in here I
think that's why I saved the potion
yeah maybe go back oh my god Rachel okay
six like five hits
[Music]
nope Oh Joey okay Oh Joey I got those
[Music]
yeah Oh run into the spike right at the
end oh my god
oh holy come on another store please
Oh locked off Oh down I go down
yeah no which one did you pick did you
pick the 1 2 or 3 1 I think this is one
right like that means like yes a number
one it gets much easier nice it's like
yeah it's shorter but like I don't even
know if it's shorter much fun only one
for sha do your poem go somewhere safe
first
yes yes yes
you
Wow good shot of a risky gamble no cash
for this yeah I guess oh okay
oh good got four ways ago these three
with three different ways then you gotta
go
any guy key yeah hold on to that let's
do like a fun store verse
chance of power is awesome awesome oh
okay we're good down
let's clear the left and right oh yeah
all right dopes okay oh okay that was it
just annoyingly oh okay it's not saying
to try using the aim lock more maybe
yeah do I have that I don't think I
turned it on
usually if you hold left button yes is
l1 they'll set to do it will stay locked
okay we're done with this place off
[Music]
one more to go
let's see if we can do it you'll need
let me turn on the aim lock I think that
I think that'll be a good perk to use
there's a 4/5 Wow oh also like look it
says like I didn't notice at the bottom
yeah like hoarders Raiders poison
countdown so I think those are the kinds
of things I encountered Museum and
divisor bikes your own spikes but yeah
you picked it dizzy says the aim lock is
a permanent I'm reading you don't need
to equip it um maybe I didn't get it
maybe I was just reading the UH the cool
tip or something where the
this is just press it while aiming and
you're good he's not enough so put near
everything this one crease your chance
to find some weapons I'll buy it
it's your kick oh oh oh no Joey
oh the squandering all this life Wow
right I pick Speights
closer
[Music]
Oh up
yeah over here nice some people claim
that we do have it both ways
hmm say it's a one trying the bumper so
if you aim and then hold the bumper yeah
Oh aiming there saying like without
moving up I've been like it locked
you're aiming position no no no okay
yeah okay that makes things a lot better
Oh Shh that's that she flips there we go
nice
careful the spike sound whoa I know see
man okay I got a sweet to be aware at
all times
[Music]
okay I got some g5 health I go down
oh no no some of these spikes Joey
[Music]
oh I don't know where no whatever
happens like yep all right yeah rather
not find out
[Music]
we good fun Apple couple Apple and we're
good let's see let's go down come on
straight football oh I really want to
see by that boss I'm just getting real
nervous I know we is there a Lachlan
somewhere
oh man that's not cool
gotta get that guy
keep shooting those out we did it
is that a third one yeah are you ready
though take you open that we're gonna go
the boss so ya want to try to go to that
only one more room there that's a gamble
we take though right like this room
could just get us less health but it
could it could help us let's take a look
[Music]
I don't think the help now
that equaled out okay yeah I was going
to have to go
[Music]
oh god that goes jam
[Music]
come bounty never knew what hit them
Bonjour hello yo horn yo hello we're
just talking about your lovely country
of France if that is where you're from
Matthew if you are from France and in
the chat tell us if you have ever seen a
mime just wandering around them yeah
it's very important we know we know
Philippe for research purposes all right
so you get a little bit of help a bubble
it all right okay okay she's that bot
all right store before the snow all
right I believe in you Joey he's also
got a lobes some space meet right there
so get that one either maybe I know what
to do now No
not starting up good oh oh there's Matt
so starfish I can kill seems like like
only when they're not spinning like that
okay
maybe
now go after the tail yeah
oh good ones okay every time I hit a
section off so yeah we want to try and
darkish care of all our fish okay there
we go yeah I don't want to get too many
of them oh boy yeah no unpublish
dropping the bombs
[Music]
my question bombs are super useful they
it's hard to witness guy moves yeah yes
so I think I only do two at a time -
what - uh two sections before he like
covers it back up okay
[Music]
one starfish down over another one
thank goodness for that bounce yes
that's a useful ability protip Oh No
dizzy death since we can start an
offshoot at GameSpot called mine spot Oh
like it I just realized that that's a
look a siren alarm honest but you notice
that oh yeah like when when the about to
bubble it back up or something yeah it's
like where or what that guy yeah I'm
good you're good you're good
those shooting a want more oh boy there
you go this might be the last
they were here
[Music]
nice
ah ha man moving so quick got this
mm got the joint oh wait okay okay yeah
yeah oh good job yay bad Billy bullseye
Rex is now available in the black market
screw you oh are you crying about that
whaling is really funny oh that's our
ghost son that's what I'm assuming it is
[Music]
fifteen health despair ah the world
actually hello take the stairs from the
hook up what hook just use the stairs
what'd we get oh we got a bounty
we're now on trail of gold feathers
numbered yeah it's a bird
so I guess and that's that brings us to
the next area next area and then we
don't have to be start over like we
wouldn't have to do this Boston not only
get if we died these chickens Fisto so
that's probably where it is a little
more roguelite then because like a
roguelike would make you start from the
beginning
giveaway understand this game does not
at least it seems that way
seven little eight bunch of card packs
here how are we on time by the way uh we
are at 12:25 s actually uh pretty good
time to stop actually with maybe I kind
of want to see me maybe the next area to
see if it changes and yeah um could you
like one level and so we yeah let's get
some stuff check out the black market
what's what's the new guy Billy you
unlock the hardcore roll is a weekly
item okay
dumbbell more speed in Turks get the
frost globe gold flawless bowels but
Swift slowdown increase the intensity of
your slow-mo field like girls gold see
someone asking about Taco Bell's new
naked chicken chips what is it re
analyzing triangles of temptation um
I've not heard of these I have I've
heard them I seem a gash from our social
team he has tried them I believe all
that just um also if goob is still in
the chat I know that he has eaten them
before
Oh Tom post picture on Twitter I tried
that the naked chicken chalupa Michele
hmm it was um not bad good no I wouldn't
it wasn't like oh man this is amazing I
have to get this again but it wasn't I
didn't have a bad experience that's
always that's always a good sign that's
always a good thing to say after you go
into Taco Bell right gooses are
essentially just chicken nuggets in
trying and trying triangle form and try
school just gonna free hook I mean
that's how I would describe that naked
chicken choucas like yeah it's like a
taco if instead of a corn shell it was
just like chicken
dizzi does says they are very goog does
say any nuggets are better with not you
a cheese sauce I think not your cheese
sauce makes anything better so what is
about nacho cheese sauce like you know
like going into a you know what it is
like or actually no you don't know what
is sure but for some reason I feel like
a lot of people just like it yeah it's
this melty cheese thing but it's like
disgusting in them in a way where is
like it's not really cheese oh yeah I
like the Taco Bell melty cheese like
it's probably one of the farthest things
away from real cheese that you can that
you can have yeah but it's so good man
very immediately some way more dangerous
so it's fun though
[Music]
oh I greet group ignorance is bliss when
it comes to nacho cheese okay yes I
already got me through Oh God
smack oh if we are reading the twitch
comments as well as the YouTube comments
so we got we got both twitch and YouTube
chat open
[Music]
okay loser bounced up heads all right Oh
perfect and this is you all along I
could get fun or annoying I'm trying to
get down from here let me through
okay wow I'm impressed
[Music]
this is Frost glue I'm gonna try this
one if you had to pick between two
pieces of merch what would you pick a
speedo or B glasses scratch wait what do
you mean which merch like I said we had
to pick between two objects a speedo or
glass looks crap like we have to wear
one of them I guess so
I don't know I guess the glasses trip
what I be restless directly well the one
that connects your glasses around the
back of your neck
oh I don't they don't fall off oh the
viewing like old people wear yeah okay
yeah I guess I didn't old people also
wear Speedos but oh my god yeah that's
true I guess in this case um we have to
promote ourselves with one interest okay
this is interesting uh hypothetical oh
no um you're like this well it's like
your body and then like your soul your
ghost soul came out of it awesome good
oh man
let's give it one more run all right
we'll get one more quick run and then
where it will close the stream out all
right that's cool extra slow down kinda
like that Oh someone saying you can jump
higher from bouncy stuff if you hold
jump and lower if you hold down people
Jill so I guess like ghost run you're
bouncing you can affect that
the level design here pretty good I like
yeah the aesthetic of all all these mics
there are deceptive yeah one round
zib on just keeps throwing the weird
hypothetical hypotheticals at us it's a
Spartan hair you have 15 seconds to get
it out I kill myself I just like my
don't even get it my myself on fire and
die he's not saying you have to do
something in order to get out just like
oh by the way little spider in your hair
now what just it's just there yeah what
but I'm dead that's I don't care oh I've
left this mortal coil gives us speed run
oh I wish it's it's a kind of tricky to
speed run because I stop you with these
uh yeah but I mean it's the idea is just
like killing this fast oh my gun broken
if I get hit by those Oh like a hippo
those dumb tricity things orbs oh no
Joey I forgot to tape record on the our
secondary was fine that's okay house it
was it we didn't need it it was just
more if we wanted to have to back up
come game of the year when we're going
to be like Oh only we had recorded that
the windows will it that foot hook
footage it's our number one GameSpot
game of the year but we didn't have the
footage as no one played it simple Jon
Lajoie
so anything come
hey those guys are adorable yeah really
well plumps on things
well that slows down did try it
whoa get through here or now there we go
oh we go it's gonna ask you could shoot
those gonna say some of the men but do
you unlock more range on your gun uh I
don't think so keep moving here oh man
all that's tricky Oh
Oh anymore and these guys are just
standing here we're floating at least it
makes sense in this area where you're
not just worrying about that yeah down
whoa we got 200 gold I can put it
sharpshooter blast you say death could
be waiting for you each time you enter
new room
now that's gambling okay colleagues
making pets
do those bombs also hurt the enemies no
cousin when I began I cool
yeah yep all right did it we did it
boots mess that show
would you rather have a million dollars
or a nice mother-in-law well I already
have a nice mother-in-law
so I will pick the million dollars or is
that imply if you pick the million
dollars your mother-in-law become no
longer becomes nice oh uh uh it's a big
million dollars all right yeah it's good
place to end it yeah thank you everyone
joining us for Flint hook this is the
thing we enjoy you're gonna be doing
every Friday at 11:00 we'll be playing a
game we're going to try and keep it in
the smaller game focus for you um so
yeah if you have any uh any suggestions
for things only might you want to see us
play you know you can hit us up on
Twitter or leave a comment and down
below or something like that I'll try to
get to it yeah see you guys next week oh
oh and stay tuned at two o'clock Jake
and I Rob I believe we're going to be
playing that next mock it up so another
indie games yes stay tuned for the
location phone hi guys